on va jouer au baccalauréat tu es dans
le before là là je vous dis aujourd'hui
démarre on va jouer au bac et vous le
savez moi je lui ai l'année dernière
c'est moi que je suis était le seul à
l'avoir qui va piquer mon bac
aujourd'hui donc c'est très simple
aujourd'hui vous a essayé de piquer mon
bac
dans un premier temps vous allez vous
affrontez de pars donc deux parts de bam
bam bam bam y en a un qui affrontera
qu'il y ait said assez content si aucun
des deux ne répond bien les deux sont
éliminés vous informer que tirer pour la
question bien sûr c'est le premier sert
à guy hoquet le dernier qui restera on a
le droit de m'affronter turin bac à
trois points d'accord sans aucune aide
extérieure qu'avec sans aucune aide
extérieure j'enlèverai l'oreillette
on relève également mon slip est vrai
tout ce que je peux relever d'accord les
chéris il n'arrivera attention premier
combat une question français enfin
questions de français et oppose
regardez qui j'ai trouvé afin de fumer
dans les toilettes literies novelli quel
évènement unique entre benjamin castaldi
à ouchy à l'été 2010 née en 2012 ça va
ça m'agace à dîner en 2008 140 question
pensez-vous jouer également chez vous un
nul en français quel est l'auteur du
chef-d'oeuvre du côté de chez swann
saisie mais non mais non au nom moba son
groupe à l'élite mais ça va pas et
genève mais non
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien tout c'est bien sûr marseille
[Musique]
j'adore
merci j'ai répété ce que vous m'avez
souffler il faut pas écouter tout ce que
dit on a été éliminés tous les deux en
tout cas bravo pour l'accusation entend
prout prout je sais pas où vous êtes
éliminés
j'en referai plus changeant attention
philosophie oh la la
valérie côtoient jean michel haag a
complété cette citation de socrate ce
que je sais ah oui c'est que je ne sais
pas c'est rien c'est rien série est rien
[Applaudissements]
et que je ne t'ai rien merci bien
surpasser pour les devises en tp
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
johnson heures vous êtes qualifiés à
bravo à maxime galy contre gilles a je
sais que vous êtes vous détestez tout
quoi voter oui mais vous l'inventé pas
attention sur une question au ps à aulas
éducation physique et sportive
aulas combien y at-il de convertir de
combien y at-il de tournois du grand
chelem au tennis j'ai le 4 way non mais
faut dire le plus rapide mais
nominatives vous pouvez vous les citez
oui à wimbledon roland garros
les internationaux d'australie et les
internationaux des états unis
[Applaudissements]
attention isabelle contre bernard qui
met bien et littérature c'est une
question paléontologie une question
anglais anglais
traduisez moelleux verbes irréguliers
jeter en anglais et conjuguer le mois
auprès des rites et au participe passé
c'est-à-dire comme dans les verts mais
régulé nord sous sol oslo
le verbe soir et aussi à sochaux pas mal
ainsi au cas où tu as everyone to fuck
fuck her géraldine contre aujourd'hui à
la haye
c'est chaud ah oui hélas l'année mec
c'est bête ça c'est comme s'il federer
et nadal se rencontrent au premier tour
c'est gentil pour les jours allawi à mon
avis le gagnant va aller au bout
question latin où la langue morte à
kaboul aura d'user moi cette phrase
traduisez moi cette phase du latin j'ai
pas fait de la thune phrase qu'on
retrouve d'ailleurs dans une chanson de
notre ami georges brassens
ces flux que tous aient fluctuat avec
mergitur fluctuat nec mergitur c'est
quoi c'est aussi la devise de paris ne
coule pas maël quoi nantes ne coule pas
oui non non non navigue non non c'est
elle tangue mais ne sombre pas le flop
mais ne coule pas dans le même esprit on
va dans parce qu'elles flottent un
flotte c'est à dire qu on flotte à hong
kong
c'est à dire que maintenant on t'aurait
plus ou moins du temps on peut dire
aussi ma vie
on peut dire aussi navigant franchement
oui oui mais oui mais oui quoi c'est
alors jean lucas qualifie oui
jean luc est connu
mais à oui il en reste quatre il se
tenait les 3 4 attention c'est une
question pour vous départager c'est une
question de chiffres et j'ai posé une
question
celui qui sera doute le plus près
gagnera il faut trois secondes pour
répondre on écrit donc trois secondes
pour répondre vous avez cinq secondes
aller pour écrire votre réponse sur
votre arbre à celui qui sera le plus
près de la réponse sera qualifié pour la
finale contre moi et tentera de me
piquer mon bac et demain on mettra en
jeu et sous encore des sous au jour des
sous what is dessous un téléphone coûte
480 euros
si l'on me fait une réduction de 35% or
quel prix baissent de payer aller vite
c'est le plus rapide à laisser les bleus
est d'aider à les rédui diddy combs et
recueilleront laisse aller vite à les
violer nos lecteurs y aller alors je
suis venu vous dire mon téléphone coûte
480 euros si l'on me fait une réduction
de 35%
quel privilège le payer ce sera contre
5% 480 ses 168 away et c'est donc 312
euros a cédé à 320 300 à 320 j'aiderai
dans mes gilles a dépassé et oui comme
dans le juste prix c'est si les gens me
fait envie
c'est donc jean mi
[Applaudissements]
joli vous allez donc tenté de me piquer
mon bac vous allez me après deux mois
jean-mi et quelqu'un va nous poser des
questions
les chéris donc il y aura trois
questions c'est le premier arrivé à deux
points nadine autre abîme avec la
pousser la personne qui pose des
questions des questions mais je ne sais
pas alors elles sont est ce qu'on peut
voir les questions alors il paraît que
c'est là dedans les barres de toit des
jaunes finale à celui qui répond bien à
deux questions gagner le jeu alors comme
syrie et le champion le challenger le
droit de donner une réponse au premier
si c'est la bonne il marque le point on
passe à la question suivante d'accord y
compris henriette première question
question sciences et vie de la terre
quels organes du corps humain est
composé de deux oreillettes et de deux
ventricules je le sais le cas britt et
ça c'est une bonne réponse le premier
arrivé à 2 juste pour savoir qui est
pour moi qu'est pour janvier vous le
saviez vous bien sûr on vous et vos amis
ou vos amis vos gens me bon vous oui
vous vous cyril jean-mi niveau
professionnel vous marc je mens et je
sais qu'elle est toujours contre moi
donc c'est jean-louis aller contre
attention je vous rappel c'est le
premier quart les deux points jean
michel à un point plus droit à l'erreur
pour cirer la deuxième question question
géographique centenaire naviguèrent
devise est inscrite sur le drapeau du
brésil à internet non non on sait déjà
qu'il ya horde m2 dont elle est
meilleure on t'aime ma part tout bien il
faut le voile alors est ce que moi je
sais juste oui mais je m'en fous ce qui
fait très chaude heures je crois qu'on a
une caméra d'or juste pour voir s'il
fait toujours aussi chaud
oui c'est vrai quoi là il met tellement
chaud dehors est ce qu'on peut vérifier
wee aa oui
oui ah bah oui on regarde il fait
tellement chaud il ya des gens qui
autorise mais non mais oui mais oui mais
non voix oui ah oui ordonne et pour les
progrès sont voilà oui alors alors
[Applaudissements]
voilà la question c'est est-ce que vous
n'avez pas honte
ah non pas pour l'instant tout va bien
quelle devise inscrite sur le drapeau du
brésil
c'est à vous de répondre deviendront les
woerth m
ouais ouais prax est ordem ces projets
sont proposés aux agressions au beso ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire si tu dois
de l'ordre tu va progresser j adore dans
ta chambre tu au rangement tâche en vous
par les portugais depuis combien de
temps vos l'a écouté les formes ont ça
va vous paraître étonnant mais la devise
du drapeau du brésil c'est ordem et
progresso et progrès or d'après cisco
guérit bien sûr les chéris on va donc
devoir se départager sur la prochaine
question est ce que vous allez me piquer
mon bac je le sens pas jean michel six
alors c'est le bac blanc s'est joué
[Applaudissements]
okah qui ramené mon bac 1 oui faut juste
les gars quand vous faites un faux
baghdadia lumière bac en sciences
j'avais eu un bac en sciences
économiques et sociales je sais pas du
tout j'ai un mac des epn 74 merci mamie
et surtout vous l'avez eu comme en 2001
à 26 ans
alors c'est bien et vous avez vu c'est
jean marc monteil au frère de patrick
bernard montiel alors y allez on y va
allez c'est parti
alors je vous appelle vous est à un
partout à tout se joue sur cette
question histoire histoire cette foire
en histoire tous les deux oui j'ai des
notions alors dans le calendrier
républicain quel nom était attribuée au
25e jour du mois de germinal exactement
le temps des demies enfin je sais pas
dire là dessus on me dit qu'en fait
juste parce que j'ai un truc en fait il
ya quelqu'un qui voudrait nous parler
d'islam allemands tombés à l'eau qui son
attention
qu'est-ce que vous avez essayé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la question donc c'était quoi c'est très
étonnant parce qu'en fait on dit que
quelqu'un veut me parler vous entendez
les oiseaux arrivée à damas alors la
question c'était dans le calendrier
républicain quel nom était attribuée au
25e jour du mois de germinal là ce ne
serait pas lui qui joue à dijon
[Applaudissements]
rien
merci n'avais pas le bac mais chérie je
suis le seul animateur à faire les
méchants qui patronne
[Applaudissements]
ah ah